I don't really know like I I don't I'm
not too familiar with the Islamic like
what they do with the mosque but I'll
give you an example right so when I was
like 18 my family we went to uh it was
like 18 19. we went to I can't remember
where I think it was like Abu Dhabi or
somewhere in the Middle East and we all
went as a family a super fun trip and
um I remember we went into like one of
the mosques and you had to put on
um the like I don't know what they're
called the hair covering stuff and you
know my mom and my dad really explained
to me that you are in someone else's
like religious uh place you're in
another country you need to follow their
rules these are their rules and so you
know I so we did and there wasn't you
know a question but people like this
it's like they're playing pretend
they're pretending to be married they're
pretending to be a husband and wife but
really it's just two porn stars putting
on a show